en france pour l'instant le débat sur la
légalisation de la consommation des
drogues drogue par dans dites douces
comme le cannabis n'est toujours pas
ouvert aux etats unis en revanche dans
l'état de californie nos dispositions
spéciales vient de la rendre légalement
accessibles en tant que traitement
médical d'appoint reportage laurent
poussier
et c'est comme ça tous les jours donc ce
salon rococo au troisième étage d'un
immeuble donnant sur l'un des cars pour
les plus populaires de san francisco ils
sont des centaines à venir chaque après
midi acheter et fumer en toute légalité
de la marijuana
vous êtes au cannabis buyers club le
club des acheteurs de cannabis une
curieuse boutique ouverte depuis cinq
mois depuis que les électeurs
californiens ont voté la proposition de
115 autrement dit la légalisation de la
marijuana à des fins médicales
pour entrer ici il faut une carte de
membre assez facile à obtenir grâce à
une ordonnance médicale en californie de
plus en plus de médecins reconnaissent
les vertus apaisantes de la marijuana
pour soulager les douleurs physiques et
morales des malades atteints du sida ou
d'un cancer grave au cannabis bailleur
club chacun revendique le droit au
bonheur passagers
j'ai le sida et sans barry juana je ne
mangerai pas je continuerai à maigrir
j'ai eu un accident de voiture très
grave si complètement café sans
marijuana je ne peux pas dormir
j'ai un glaucome et sans mal wanadoo
serait déjà à bloc
des malades qui s'y trouve de tout
depuis l'herbe californienne la
meilleure paraît-il à 60 dollars environ
360 francs les trois grammes et demi
jusqu'au biscuits et gâteaux aux
feuilles de cannabis à 30 ou 40 francs
le promoteur de ce club c'est lui dennis
ferrer
je suis la vague hippie dans les années
60 il est de tous les combats pour la
légalisation de la marijuana pour lui le
club est plus qu'un simple endroit où
fumer un joint
en surface vous ne voyez que la
marijuana mais c'est davantage un
problème de solitude un problème
d'existence face à face avec vous même
c'est un refuge pour ceux qui vont
mourir ici il retrouve un peu de dignité
quelques amis
l'herbe est acheté ici chez des
producteurs privés ils profitent du flou
juridique qui oppose les lois de l'état
californien qui autorise la production
de marijuana et les lois fédérales
américaines qui l'interdisent entre les
deux ils ont choisi en ce moment ils
préparent les plans pour l'année
prochaine mais leur culture est discrète
à l'écart des grandes agglomérations
la publicité en revanche ne fait pas
peur à dennis peron ce jour là qu il a
tenu à nous montrer la première boîte de
marijuana légal vendus aux etats unis